where are you at this point in your life
between money legacy the process if I
said if I said 30 year old you right now
between generally in your stomach in
your heart in your gut about how much
you're driven by and how much you like
the net win is around dollars is around
being able to do your process and around
legacy how are you currently broken down
between a hundred percent as well I
don't have children yet
so maybe things will change but I have
enough that I don't have to worry for
maybe a forever I find my I thought I
was really money motivated but when you
get all these like opportunities when
you get to a little bit of a level like
we'll pay you ten grand to come here do
this or whatever and I just denied and I
found myself not wanting to do that
because I don't like that sounds so
boring to me I don't want to do that so
I guess it's a question of where I am a
little bit I would I mean like one time
we had um a client do something that we
thought was an thing and we
fired them and we lost a quarter of a
million dollars and I slept like a baby
so I don't think I'm as money moded
money motivated as I thought do you
think that because you checked some sort
of box for yourself along the way versus
no I really I think I had you money
when I tinker in yeah I get that I
understand yeah I do know that like and
then what I was like wait a minute
I still don't think I've ever been more
rich than when I was doing baseball card
shows at 13
because 3000 $4000 when you're 13 and
you came from nothing set I thought I
had like a trillion I remember one day I
sold hotdogs and I had a grip of cash it
was like a great grip yeah it was just a
grip we call it I call it a grip let me
get that grip it was it was because I
have to go John are here tonight and I
had like a grand in five dollar bills
and I was like this is for me money this
is it I was I was like like we called it
hood rich and where did you grow up
again in st. Louis Missouri but then I
lived in Nashville Tennessee but I grew
up with a lot of like poor people and
you know that's why I talk like this but
I felt like it did you think about I was
happy so in Nashville I lived across the
street from the projects and we would
hang out all the time I was how old were
you then 19 to 21 a 21 and I would just
hang out there with my buddy right out
and we would just chill and just sit on
it was the most it was I was my happiest
when I had nothing which is weird right
no I think I think it's not weird at all
but uh what you guys talk about just
shoot like guy talk girls sports just
random or would you talk about
dreams business yeah I mean he this dude
had served 25 years in prison and he
would talk about that but just stupid
stuff but it was just it's really fun I
think that when you come from not a lot
which you know I had a good family and
everything but when you start from when
you trying to start on your own from
scratch you have siblings yeah yeah I've
said when older brother and older sister
you were two youngest mm-hmm yeah I
think when you start from not a lot okay
it's actually a huge advantage and you
could be a lot happier that way I think
I think if you're born to a wealthy
family the likelihood of like depression
might actually be higher I think so you
know what I mean
based on our societal norms right now so
much of my passion about like what I
talk about and the content I put out is
to create empathy for it's very hard I
you know I get it
I grew up in it it's very hard for
somebody that doesn't have much to have
empathy for somebody who's driving a BMW
and has a Rolex but you know based on
all my readings all my DM so I get at
this point of my life I have some
hundreds of thousands of interactions
per month year whatever it is it's just
a lot of interactions I see far more
sadness and people that had too much
then people had too little
I see Envy in people that don't have as
much I see drive and people that don't
have as much I see resentment and people
that don't have as much I see deep
lostness and people that had too much
you know like there's just when people
didn't have as much they there is an
inherent I'm gonna pull myself out of
this whether it's illegal legal there's
a drive it's really hard to be hungry
when you started fed it just is no and I
agree and I have I have wealthy kids and
I think about it constantly
[Music]